the biggest planet in the solar system
and the smallest star in the known
universe
today they're on a collision course and
earth might not survive this
meet the star with a catchy name eblm
j0555-57ab
its gravity is
300 times that of earth's
and it's about the size of our saturn
eblmj0555-57ab
is a red dwarf and the smallest star
we've ever discovered
usually it resides 600 light years away
from us in its own double star system
but not today
today it broke the cosmic speed limit
and rushed toward our solar system to
meet with the biggest gas giant in it
jupiter
let me just tell you jupiter is huge
it's about 11 times larger than earth
it's even bigger than the red dwarf star
coming its way but because it's mostly
made of hydrogen it's not massive enough
to be a star
to start converting all its hydrogen
into helium and turn into a red dwarf
jupiter would need to be at least 80
times more massive than it is today
so
what would happen if these two gas
giants collided
well the real collision is about to go
down in the greatest mobile game of all
time rage shadow legends
it's time to explore the world of
talaria with over 600 champions ready to
fight on your mobile device my favorite
faction the high elves nothing stands
between me and victory when i have
eleanoral as my champion
these elves have survived civil war and
hordes of orcs only to come back
stronger than ever they helped build
civilization and now they might take it
back
and there's a ton going on in raid this
month i'm talking a complete overhaul of
the champion vault 5 brand new champions
and a huge summer splash series of
events grab this skin of my favorite
dwarf trenda oh and one more thing make
sure you get in now if you want to be
part of it hey this is the time to
explore the vast world of raid if that's
what i love about this game there's so
much to see and customize yeah the best
rpg around isn't on some overpriced
console it's available right now on your
phone
click on the link in the description
below or scan my qr code here and you'll
get unique bonuses worth thirty dollars
oh and check this out a free epic
champion hyena 200 000 in silver one
energy refill one xp boost and one
ancient shard
yeah you can summon champions now and
get all this loot when you click below
and all this treasure will be waiting
for you here you know champions will
clash and raid but these celestial
titans are ready to collide now
before the interstellar red dwarf could
even make it to jupiter it would have to
pass through the oort cloud
the oort cloud is a collection of icy
comets and other bodies on the edge of
our solar system
as the smallest star in the known
universe was passing through this icy
debris it would wreak big havoc in our
planetary neighborhood
yeah it would send icy comets our way
and some of them would start hitting
earth
we'd have to think of a way to protect
our planet from this comet shower
but time would not be on our side
because the smallest star in the
universe would keep moving toward
jupiter
our stellar guest might be smaller in
size than jupiter but it sure would be
more massive
ebl
mjo555-57ab's gravitational pull would
start to tug on the planet
and don't forget that we'd now have a
second star in our solar system
things would start getting hot
all the heat from the red dwarf plus its
strong gravity would make jupiter grow
in size
the gas giant's atmosphere would puff up
as all the gases were heating up and
expanding
some of jupiter's atmosphere would start
to escape into space and toward the
stellar intruder
eventually all the runaway jupiter gases
would form a hot ring around
eblmj555-57ab
it would look as if we had a black hole
in the solar system only it would be
really bright
the red dwarf star would keep slowly
ripping jupiter apart
now it would be eating whole chunks of
our gas giant
for a moment jupiter would take the
shape of an american football but
soon enough the star would engulf it
entirely
sorry jupiter you didn't stand a chance
but now we'd be in a real pickle
jupiter would no longer exist in the
solar system and now we'd have an alien
red dwarf star surrounded by a ring of
hot gases
our solar system wouldn't be the same
without jupiter this gas giant wasn't
here for a cool view
jupiter's gravity usually attracts
asteroids and comets that make it into
our planetary neighborhood
it gobbles them up before they make it
further into the solar system
with no jupiter to protect us from all
the space rocks
earth would be getting bombarded by all
kinds of debris icy comets asteroids
you name it
every day we'd be hit by about
170 meteors comets and asteroids
that's 10 times more than what's making
it to our planet right now
life here would sure get more dangerous
who knows how long before one really big
asteroid would come and destroy all life
on our planet
but things would get even worse
having another star in our solar system
would disrupt the orbits of all the
planets that passed
including earth's
of course it would take eblmj0555-57
millions of years to rampage all the way
to our sun so you might stay alive long
enough to witness the epic slow motion
chaos
unless the red dwarf sent another planet
on a collision course with us
yeah
that would end things much much quicker
all the planetary collisions in the
solar system would create a rippling
effect
the planetary orbits would get disrupted
even more as time passed
earth could even get knocked out of its
orbit entirely
this would send you and everything else
on the planet on a rogue trip across the
universe
and without the sun to give us warmth
the earth would turn into a frigid
lifeless rock very soon
if you somehow survived up to this point
you wouldn't have very long now
now of all the things that could enter
our solar system the smallest star in
the universe might not be the worst
how about a black hole
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you